alors que les espagnols placés au
chômage partiel en mars ne se sont
toujours pas vu verser leurs allocations
chômage par l'état beaucoup ne paient
plus leur loyer depuis le mois dernier
c'est le cas de bertha qui travaillait
dans l'hôtellerie avant la crise du coc
vite 19
elle vient tout juste de retrouver un
emploi dans une résidence médicalisée
avec quel argent on va payer les loyers
en ce moment on reçoit déjà les factures
les factures de gaz d'électricité et il
faut les payer mais avec tous ces gens
qui n'ont plus de travail d'où va-t-on
sortir l'argent pour payer tous ces
frais de la maison le gaz l'électricité
l'eau et en plus le loyer
donc oui je soutiens la grève des loyers
en espagne un retard d'un mois de loyer
est suffisant pour que le propriétaire
puisque lancer une procédure d'expulsion
mais sous la pression des associations
de défense du droit au logement le
gouvernement espagnol a décrété un
moratoire sur les expulsions immobilière
jusqu'au 2 octobre prochain les
fournisseurs d'eau d'électricité et de
gaz ont également l'interdiction de
suspendre leurs services dans les
résidences principales des citoyens dans
toutes les expulsions sans solution de
relogement pour les personnes
vulnérables sont suspendues à partir
d'aujourd'hui et jusqu'à six mois après
la fin de l'état d'urgence
personne ne peut être expulsée de son
domicile dans des contrats de location
en cours qui sont sur le point d'expirer
sont automatiquement prolongé de six
mois
la même mesure qui dans la pratique
signifie qu'aucun locataires en espagne
ayant un contrat en cours ne pouvoir
sont noyés augmenté au cours des six
prochains mois
l'exécutif propose aussi des micro
crédits publics à taux préférentiel est
remboursable sur 10 ans insuffisant
voire complètement inapproprié pour les
associations comme la plate forme anti
expulsions et de défense du droit au
logement qui demande l'annulation pure
et simple des loyers pour les personnes
sans revenu à la suite de la crise du
coc vide 19
la réalité c'est que seulement 10% des
familles qui en ont besoin
pouvoir accéder aux crédits de l'état et
car les critères sont tellement
restrictif que presque personne ne
pourra les avoir et en plus ce que
l'état propose à ces familles dans le
besoin c'est de s'endetter pour pouvoir
payer le loyer aux grands propriétaires
et aux fonds spéculatifs qui viennent
spéculer en espagne donc ce que nous
demandons c'est qu'il y ait une
annulation de ces loyers de la part de
ses grands propriétaires à barcelone par
exemple le parc locatif est détenue à
33% par des grands propriétaires le
gouvernement travaillait également sur
la création d'un revenu minimal vitale 2
500 euros par mois pour les plus démunis
un décret en ce sens doit être publié
très prochainement